Tracy and Allen the benefits of driving
electric vehicle are pretty well known
no more trips to the gas station but
consider what could happen if there's a
problem with the major component in that
vehicle that's what happened to the
driver in our story
tonight I felt like I got kicked in the
privates simrat s is still feeling the
pain over what recently happened with
his electric vehicle I was an electric
fan and I want to get another electric
vehicle but from Hyundai this has really
put a bad taste in my mouth towards
them Hyundai's 2017 ionic was launched
in New York with great Fanfare in 2016
the ionic
electric a hybrid version and a fully
electric model bought by S he was the
second owner but the car still had lots
of warranty left on the electrical
system and battery at the time and since
s had previously owned a different
electric vehicle he was a Believer
didn't have any issues with my first
vehicle so thought it would be the right
Avenue to try a second vehicle he had no
issues with the car until this happened
I had an EV light come on I had had
taken it to the shop they couldn't find
anything wrong but there was indeed a
problem 2 weeks after that the vehicle
stopped charging the dealership in
Hamilton said he needed the battery
replaced the quote stunned him I was
provided a quote at
$50,000 between the battery installation
and taxes it totaled just over $50,000 I
was just floored especially because his
160,000 km electric vehicle warranty had
just run out the dealer at Hyundai told
Su there was nothing they could do I
still had to pay $500 for them to tell
me the car's no good stories like this
one are the kind to scare off buyers
concerned about the high cost of
electric vehicle repairs when confronted
with the choice to fix or dispose of his
powerless Hyundai ionic he chose the
ladder I ended up scrapping the vehicle
and collecting around $1,000 but when
Global News asked Hyundai Canada to
investigate we were told there had been
a Communications breakdown at the head
office level the case should have been
escalated immediately for additional
review they told us we extend our
sincere apologies to Mr Su for these
laps adding it wanted to resolve this
situation by paying fair market value
for his vehicle either in cash or
towards a new Hyundai as part of our
commitment to our customers Hyundai's
decision could put 25 or $30,000 in
such's Pocket toward a new vehicle
replacing a car he
scrapped so sush will be able to get
into a new vehicle which is good news
that because Hyundai stepped up after we
got involved but if you're considering
electric vehicle this is something to
take quite seriously the idea that a
component like the battery could fail
and it could cost you tens of thousands
of dollars when you probably can't
expect it Allan great news for that
driver that you got involved thank you
Sean